a large majority of sex offenders use
power as an influence of their offending
behavior and i think that power played
massively into him you know he was a
completely narcissistic egotistical
control freak and had his way you know
nearly all the time so when he thought
that well i want it i'll have it he just
went and did it and of course nobody
challenged him he was fairly untouchable
he was fairly unchallengeable and he
lived a consistent lie
how do you describe what you do for work
well i think now it's probably as an
investigative reporter i do do some
private consultancy and i also run a
risk management consultancy where i
investigate and help organizations with
dangerous offenders
so i'm a pretty busy person
but you used to be a police officer
right so what's the difference
between a police officer and an
investigator
so yeah former police detective and not
a massive amount certainly not the way
that i do it i mean there are
many different investigators out there
who do things in different ways but my
ethos and the way i operate is very much
along the same lines as if i were a
detective obviously i don't have the
powers of being a detective i don't have
the warrant but what i do have is the
skills that i've learned from being a
police detective and i just transfer
them into the roles that i do now i have
the same ethical approach i have the
same
moral approach in terms of how i do
things and all of my investigations are
built around as if i was doing it for a
criminal investigation so the same
levels of standards apply
what are some of the restrictions that
you have placed on yourself obviously
you're not going to be able to go and
arrest people so is it your job as an
investigator to put together a
a kind of case and then pass that up to
authorities that can bring people to
justice how does it work
yes so obviously i don't have a power of
arrest so i can't force people to talk
to me i can't force people to come with
me and do things but
as an investigator in the way that i
work within the media
often that actually doesn't make that
much of a difference because what it
does mean is that people will talk to me
and they'll often talk to me
when they wouldn't talk to the police
and they'll give me information that
they wouldn't or don't give to the
police so i have
a great opportunity i think when i go
and do these investigations as not being
a police officer that said of course i
don't have access to the records that
police officers do so i can't gain as
much information about people
but what i have to use is my own sources
and also
the open source data that exists around
the internet to try and find information
about people when i'm doing an
investigation
my ethos always is about helping people
so whenever i take on any investigation
the starting point is can i make a
difference because
more often than not by the time people
have come to me as they've tried
everything else they've failed with the
police they've failed with all the other
organizations or media outlets
and they come to me in desperation can i
help them and what i will never want to
do is to give people false hope it is
about being realistic to them so if i
can't genuinely can't see anything that
i can do as far as adding value i'm no
wizard but what i do is obviously
thoroughly investigate and use my skills
very successfully if i can't help them
then i'll be honest up front and say
look there's there's nothing i can do
because there's nothing worse than being
given false hope
it seems crazy that you without access
to
records and fingerprints and so on and
so forth
that you can do more than the police
i guess it shows the power of finding
sources getting information from people
using those i guess what would you call
them sort of softer styles of
investigation
yeah i mean i i wouldn't say in every
circumstance i'm better than the police
at all i think what i can provide is a
uniqueness in terms of a dedicated
approach of course the police have you
know huge workloads my workloads are
high but they're in a very different way
so i have to prioritize and say i'm
going to really focus on this case now
and just just
totally look at it put everything else
to one side whereas the police can't
always do that they have to manage a
number of cases at the same time
are you legally allowed to surveil
people if you're not the police
yeah absolutely so not necessarily in
some foreign countries it's bit
problematic certainly in portugal
there's not meant to be doing any
private investigations but uh i have
done it in portugal and i've done it in
many other countries but in the uk
absolutely no problems at all you know
you have to be aware of people's privacy
and you have to do it in a certain way
but you can absolutely do surveillance
on people and i very regularly do do
you tap people's phones is that
something that's allowed
no you can't do that and in fact the
police
can't do that without very high
authority
so you can't do anything that's overly
intrusive what you can do of course is
use techniques that enable you to gain
access to people so sometimes you know
we might run a decoy we might run a
courier pretending to to look for
somebody or deliver a package and that
will often lead to identifying where
somebody is
we might use trackers
uh we might use listening devices all of
those little techniques now which are
very readily available and easily
applied to gather intelligence but or
information but it's always about a
bigger cause you know it's about being
proportionate
if i'm investigating something for
example if it was very minor then one
has to look at the proportionality of
the techniques that you're employing the
more serious it is the more serious of
techniques that you can apply if
someone's wanted for murder or wanted
for very serious offenses and of course
the proportionality of what you're going
to deploy and use
increases
what was your role in the jimmy savile
case
well jimmy savile i was i was actually
coming back from
interpol i'd been over there making a
film for bbc news night and the producer
said to me have you ever heard anything
about jimmy savile as being a sex
offender and i said well no she's a very
strange bloke but i've never heard that
and he said there he is you know my my
aunt was a
school where he used to visit and
there's a lot of chat online about it
and he said yeah we've been looking at
it and we're looking to do something and
i said well
i've never heard anything about that
anyway then moves forward over the next
few weeks and he said look we were aware
that apparently he was arrested by a
police force either surreal sussex
do you think you can find out well i was
in surrey police and and i could tell
him that it didn't happen during my time
in the police so it must have happened
after that
and then when i looked into it i
established that it had been a case that
sorry police were looked at passed that
back to him and newsnight at that point
then said well we can't show any
failings by the police so we're going to
drop it
and he said to me you know he's like i'm
going to run it and i said well that's
mad because i've now done some digging
myself and there clearly looks to be
something there that still needs an
awful lot of work to stand it up i mean
they were a long way away from standing
up a program to make any
any
uh
any difference
and i said well let me let me look at it
so i did so i set off on the path to try
and establish victims and see what the
accounts were and as a direct result of
that 12 months later
made a program and kind of the rest is
history really you know third of october
2012 was a pretty momentous occasion not
just in terms of
showing what jimmy savile did but
actually making a difference for the
rest of certainly the uk and actually
had ramifications around the world i
think if it hadn't been for
jimmy savile's exposure
i wonder whether weinstein
and the other individuals who have now
been exposed
not
we now need to available hold of this
and we now to start to listen to people
who are telling us about what's going on
you know no longer should people be
untouchable and and i think there was a
a massive massive change in attitudes as
a direct result of that program going
out i think you're right the reckoning
around men in positions of power abusing
that power to gain access to either
women or minors
i mean was it ralph harris who was also
downstream from that who was the who was
the media guy in the uk so there's max
clifford ralph harris yeah um yeah there
was a there was the the knockout guy i
can't remember his name now you know um
bill
bill cosby you know there's a number of
individuals certainly ralph harris and
max clifford you know i was
instrumentally involved in both of those
cases as far as bringing them to the
police and getting the police to
investigate them
and you know people turn around
afterwards there were some critics who
said yeah you're just going after the
celebrities well what they didn't
realize is as a result of getting those
people who were the most powerful
untouchable
it meant anybody was touchable it meant
anybody could be got therefore up and
down the country teachers scout masters
you know those people in positions of
trust who were having access to children
were being arrested and i can tell you
the knock-on effect of that was
phenomenal you know we got contacted by
the nspcc in the weeks after the
program went out just telling us the
massive difference
that has the result of our programs made
to the amount of people calling into
their hotline and the amount of cases
that were coming in and i know because
of my work with police forces up and
down the country that they saw a
significant spike in new cases and as a
result of that
victims coming forward and offenders
being caught and i think it genuinely
did
make offenders think that the next knock
on the door could well be from the
police yeah i mean if you can get a
harvey weinstein or a an epstein or a
rolf harris or whoever
you can get anyone
it really does sort of plant a flag in
the ground and say okay you think that
you're safe in your position of power as
like you say a teacher scout master
priest whatever it might be if you can
take down people at the top of the tree
in terms of media
it really does i suppose put the shits
at people that think
they can get away with it
being below the radar so talk to me
about the difficulties in investigating
that i mean apart from the fact
that
he was this huge media personality
i guess there must have been so many
obstacles in there
yeah huge amounts i mean i've never
spoken about it and my book talks about
the case and you know there's there's
bits and pieces that we did behind the
scenes
in order to get the program broadcast
which i've never spoken about and i
don't think i ever will do
because i for me it was about the five
women that came forward and we'd had to
do whatever we could to try and get it
broadcast and thankfully itv did
broadcast it but it was really difficult
you know there was at no stage really
during the course of that 12 month
investigation
was there any time that i thought you
know what this is a quite an easy
investigation to do
at every stage there was hurdles to face
and there was you know first of all how
many victims could we find was four
enough was five enough was six enough
was seven enough how many was enough
would we get the authorities to believe
us would we would we get the public on
our side
were people prepared to talk to us
would people give up their anonymity to
go on telly and explain that they were a
victim of abuse what was the fear of
being sued
what was the damage to us doing i mean i
remember very clearly that my producer
and i you know we we talked about it
yeah during the course of that 12 months
it was a consistent thing and i remember
saying to her once you know if we don't
if this program doesn't land right
we'll never work in telly again
um you know we put our we put ourselves
on the line absolutely to make that
program and and of course the women did
more you know those victims of his
for them it was
not only they gone through all that
abuse but for them to give up their
identity in the ways that they did
was was huge far bigger than the risk
that i took
but there was a risk you know there was
a personal risk and damage
that i may never have ever worked in
television again if we'd have got it
wrong and no one had supported us and
gone with us and even up until the last
moment i mean i remember doing an
interview for bbc radio leads the day
before the program broadcast and the
reporter there who was very supportive
of savile because savile was from leeds
was basically saying you know you who do
you think you are to be the judge and
jury you know to to put this program
together when they when the man's dead
i mean my response very clearly was and
i wrote a piece about this and said look
you know i'm not judging jury all i'm
doing is presenting the facts you are
the judging jury the public of the judge
and the jury ultimately you will decide
whether or not you believe the evidence
being presented all i'm doing is putting
it out there and then it's up to you to
make your decision
so
savile was alive when you started your
investigation
but no no he died he died by the time so
he was alive when news night started
theirs yep then he died but by the time
i started my investigation he had
already died
did the fact that he was dead make
things easier or harder
oh it would never have broadcast in a
month or some days if he'd been alive no
one would have touched it and he was
hard enough to get it touched and he was
alive when he was dead nobody would have
touched it you know i did a big piece in
the guardian about that that was very
clear that had savile still been alive
our program would not have gone off the
ground it wouldn't even move forward
there'd be no traction for it nobody
would have been interested in
broadcasting it and that tells you a lot
about the power that he had
even when he was still dead was that
just him wielding
solicitors left right and center and
threatening to sue people
yeah incredibly litigious the victims
wouldn't have stood up for it because
they'd have been sued by him
and the broadcaster wouldn't have tried
it wouldn't have trodden there because
they wouldn't have wanted to face the
backlash from him
and the financial implications from it
why is it
that so the police were notified
of this sussex police or surrey police
had been notified that there was
something to investigate
but they hadn't got anywhere with their
investigation how did it come to someone
like why was television
the place that justice was found as
opposed to in the police
well there was three allegations that
were made they went to surrey police
surrey police investigated it and as a
result of that interviewed savile at
stoke mandeville hospital interviewed
him in relation to sexual offenses
didn't make any contact with the
hospital to tell them that they were
going to interview what an individual on
their grounds for sexual offences which
is astonishing
he gave his account basically said none
of it's true absolutely rubbish
and surrey police decided to well within
conjunction with the crown prosecution
service
uh closed the case
but significantly without making any
inquiries had they have followed up on
some of the things he'd have told them
they could have shown that that wasn't
true that he was lying
and simply fell sadly
years later to me to pick it up and and
do the job properly it seems crazy that
there's things that you can do
that the police can't that there's lines
of inquiry that get chased up i suppose
you're right the fact that your
um focus is narrowed
for for a period of time really really
does make one team look at a particular
case
yeah i find that fascinating i find it
absolutely fascinating that you can have
somebody who's got the expertise and
outside of the institution that's able
to do that work
yeah i mean i'm not the only person i'm
not the only invested reporter that's
out there that does these types of
things um but it's about
you know it's also how about having the
experience and and having the ability to
go and do those things i mean the police
officers that were investigating that
case made some fatal mistakes the crown
prosecution service made some very fatal
mistakes
and
you know sadly whatever you do you know
you could you could easily say well
they're busy they're overworked they've
got so many cases that doesn't wash does
it doesn't wash at all because as far as
the victims are concerned they don't
care whether you've got another case you
know i want you to deal with my case
properly and so when one argues and says
well i'm just so busy i didn't do it
properly it's like well you shouldn't
have done it then
was there anything unique about savile
obviously he's
outwardly he's a bit of a weird guy but
was there anything particularly unique
about him that sort of came up during
your investigation as well
yeah i mean i think the uniqueness of
savile and it really is a uniqueness it
was his broad of his effect the
broadness of his offending so he
offended against predominantly women
overwhelmingly women
from all age groups from 12 13 all the
way up to 50 60 i think one of his
latest victims was 70 or something but
it but real broad range of offending
behavior which is very strange because
he quite clearly was interested in in
young children you know 14
15 around
puberty ages but he also had an interest
in women who were a lot older than that
which is very strange for an offender
you wouldn't normally have such a broad
range of offending behavior targeting
group
what do you think that says about him
well i think a lot of his effect i mean
it becomes quite a complex process but i
think in terms of offenses offenders why
do they offend
a large majority of sex offenders use
power as an influence of their offending
behavior and i think that power played
massively into him you know he was a
completely narcissistic egotistical
control freak
and had his way you know nearly all the
time
so when he thought that well i want it
i'll have it he just went and did it
and of course nobody challenged him he
was fairly untouchable he was fairly
unchallengeable and he lived a
consistent lie you know his ideas that
he was out doing lots of um
marathons and things like that i mean i
think he finished two or three marathons
in his life and he was meant to have
finished about 30 or 40. he would start
the marathon his roles would pick him up
and he'd be dropped off just before the
end and come out you know he'd go to
charity events and he'd be there for 10
minutes and he'd disappear be paid for
the full time he was a complete
charlatan you know but
very very good at it you know he he
pulled the wool over his eye and for a
large majority of people if i can work
twenty percent but get paid a hundred
percent i'll do it
and you know majority of people would
work like that do you think that him
creating his children's shows was his
way of gaining access
i think it was i wrote a piece in the
radio times and and there was a number
of people who said actually you know
that's not true
but the evidence would suggest that it
was
whether it was subconscious or whether
it was a deliberate act by him there's
no doubt that by having a
chat show or a show like jim will fix it
enabled him to get access to children
and predominantly his offending behavior
was against young people children so
whether it was subconscious or not or
whether it was a direct decision by him
i have no doubt that that played
absolutely into his offending behavior
did he ever cross over to boys or men
well there were a number of allegations
of males that he'd sexually abused who
were around the teenage years i never
saw any evidence about that and i'm not
suggesting that they weren't they aren't
correct but i never saw any evidence of
his offending against males
hmm
interesting
so is it just his power that allowed him
to get away with this for so long
yeah i think essentially i think he
became fairly untouchable and as a
result of that i mean there were people
through the over the years who could
quite easily have stopped him
uh before he became a very powerful
person but they didn't do anything about
it and as a result of that his power
increased his offending behavior
increased and he could get away with it
he knew he could get away with it he
knew that no one was ever going to
challenge him because if he did
challenge him by the time he got to such
a position he was so
um powerful
he was able to be very litigious
presumably
that means that there were other people
who were either willfully ignorant
or negligent or turned a blind eye or
perhaps even complicit i know that one
of the
bigwigs at the bbc had to resign
in the aftermath of this but do you
think that there's still more fallout
are there still more
conspirators or enablers
out there that probably do need to be
called to justice
undoubtedly i mean there are people out
there who
knew
knew that he was offending not to the
degree necessarily of what it was i
don't think anybody knew about that
other than him but there will be other
people who knew about his offending or
knew about his inappropriateness working
in the fields that he was and did
nothing about it
uh and one of the massive problems is
and
so there's a number of television
programs have been made at the moment
his anniversary is coming up very soon
and there's a number of programs that
were made that are being made around it
uh and i've not taken part in any of
those and quite simply because
you know savile now really is a matter
i've put it behind me it's it's a
position i've done the job i've i've
done my work
i've let other people now get on with
their bits but it's still unfinished in
terms of holding people to account and
until somebody wants to commission or
make a program which actually holds
people to account then i've got no
interest you know it's for me it's not
about going over you know his offending
behavior again we know that that's been
covered extensively
and what we now need to do is hold
people to account and until somebody
wants to do that and commission a
program to do that then i'm not
interested
how many people do you think he abused
well when we did the investigation we
said in excess of 500 and that might
seem strange to people but it's a figure
having worked in child protection for a
long time that i know that someone of
his age
is likely to incur that amount of
contact with that many victims and it's
interesting when we met the
officer in charge of the metropolitan
police operation utre he came to meet us
at itv
and we had a meeting and he said you
know after an initial
assessment of the case we reckon there's
probably about 30 or 40 victims and i
went 500
and he went really yeah he said well
i'll bow to your
your knowledge having investigated them
for the last year and of course
when the final report came out
there was just in excess of 500 victims
i suppose
that's what happens when you're around
for that long right if you've been in
this position of power for such a long
amount of time
it just gives you this constant access
yeah that's um
that's terrifying another thing to
consider as well that i thought was
quite interesting is obviously
louis theroux who
from what i know is a pretty shrewd guy
seems like a smart fella he's able to
exist on multiple planes at once he can
play with power dynamics within the
documentaries that he does to great
comedic effect
he didn't see it not the first time that
he met him
no i i mean i
no
i think it's when you're in immersed in
that i mean i know louis very well when
you're immersed in something like that i
think it it's very easy to have the wall
pulled over your eyes unless you step
back from it and you have the ability to
to be objective and detangle yourself
from the whole thing and i think louie
got caught up in it all
and as a result of that i actually
became friends with him i mean there's a
very strange louis through program which
was the one that he did for his last
program about several
where he said it was was really about
louie it was a very strange program
where he talked about the impact that
he's had on him about he became friends
with him he spent a lot of time with him
um
and
yeah i mean you know he
he
he had the opportunity i mean he was in
a way you could say well louie missed it
because louie had the opportunity when
he was in the car with him talking about
you know interested in children to take
it to the one step further
and and actually talk to people around
and find out those people that didn't
like saving why didn't they like him or
what was everything going on but i think
he he got caught up in it all and of
course when you are immersed in that and
you're being given access to an
individual the access they'll give you
is the access they want to give you yeah
he's the
he's
gatekeeper
the gatekeeper so you then have to step
outside that and go do you know what you
know when i investigated uh oscar
pistorius you know in terms of the case
or the program that we made for oscar
one of the things i said right at the
very beginning is oscar you know i'm
going to go to perhaps places that you
are uncomfortable with uh you know i
will i will set the scene here not you
you're giving me access but i'll take
where i will go wherever i want to go
and that might mean asking you difficult
things and he was absolutely fine with
that
you could never have done that with
jimmy savile should he say i wouldn't go
no no i'm telling you where to go he
controls the frame you are stepping into
my world
totally totally and you saw that well
you see that actually with the majority
of people that louis goes and visits you
know he's visit it's great access tv
but ultimately he's always doing it on
their terms correct yeah but that's the
that kind of side-eye
um
what's it called gonzo's style of
reporting that's that that's the way
that it works right the point is that
it's a fly on the wall sort of candid
approach yeah i think as well maybe
another thing to to play devil's
advocate for louis
savile's such an eccentric overall
you you kind of don't know what
character what's truth there's a lot
being thrown at you i mean there's that
clip that louis did put
just after he's cycling around his
living room which is like a bizarre
scene from like some
horror movie in itself
and he says there's this clip of jimmy
looking at the camera and going women
know too much i don't like women
they shouldn't know so much i think
that's
in isolation when you take it with the
frame of everything else it makes sense
but when you've got this guy that says
i'm going to go out backwards so when
people look at me they think that i'm
coming in i'm coming in forwards they
won't know whether i'm coming or going
you think right okay this is just a
litany of a [ __ ] weird guy
and i think one you're right and i think
one of the problems with savile is that
he made himself incredibly eccentric
so people didn't know
you know whether
or a lot of people just said well that's
just him yeah
that's just how he behaves that's what
he is and i think in order to properly
pull
savile apart
it also requires you having knowledge of
how offenders operate
and how devious they are and how they
operate and grooming and and you know
louie didn't have that knowledge
understandably so you know it doesn't
come from that background
so i think it's very difficult to
for anybody to have been in an
environment around savile in those days
and for the majority of people to
actually know
to pick up on it
they were he was weird you know
definitely a strange blow but you'd if
if you spent some time with him and you
had the knowledge of how offenders
operate i think alarm bells would be
ringing very quickly you reckon but
you'd have but you'd have to have that
knowledge and you'd have to spend the
time with him and you'd have to ask
searching and difficult questions and
you'd have to know how to do that so i
think it's a
he was on a pretty safe wicket wasn't he
getting louie in there because uh and
the same with max clifford you know max
clifford had louie in and you know for
both of those of course it raised some
slightly strange stuff but ultimately
they all came out of it okay
or well i'm not sure if you've seen the
andrew cuomo
uh allegations that are coming out of
america at the moment i think he's the
governor of new york and he has been
accused of being very inappropriate with
a number of the women that are in his
office
and
one of his defenses around this is that
he's a very touchy affectionate person
so there's some photos and videos that
come out and what it's made me think is
you were talking about
jimmy used his
global
personality as a smoke screen to make it
very difficult to pick out what elements
of his personality were predatory and
which elements of it were just more of
the eccentricity whereas andrew cuomo
has said pretty much exactly the same
thing
talking about he his team released a
bunch of photos or someone got a bunch
of photos together of him you know
holding hands with other men hugging
other men sort of kissing men on the
cheek just generally being overly
affectionate you think well if you
presume that someone isn't that smart
then maybe that's just the way that they
go about it but if someone's a very
clever predator
then what they can do is think right
if it does come out that
there are accusations around me having
touched people i have this huge backlog
of all of this media here that i've
created and i think um
underestimating the level of planning
that these people go to is
probably an error that we shouldn't be
making
yeah and i think actually i mean i can't
talk about his case because i don't know
it but i think also there are cases
where individuals are are very you know
contact they they do have a lot of
contact and actually what ends up
happening is that they take that contact
too far
or they end up touching somebody of
obviously when there is no consent
applied and i think that's what happens
with a lot of people and
you know when we all these people start
to be arrested and there was a lot of
chat obviously around you know these
crimes happened a long time ago well
let's be very clear a sexual assault in
the 1970s 80s and 90s is no different
than the sexual results in 2020.
you know the the nature of the offense
was the same it was about you know not
having consent to touch so nothing
changed what happens is the whole
attitude has changed slightly or
significantly because what used to be
accepted it wasn't acceptable but it was
accepted because
by reporting it nobody would do anything
you wouldn't be listening to there
wouldn't be any action from it so
people's people just simply put up with
it as a result of that
nothing was done of course then when
they have a voice and they're being
listened to and that the view is
actually you know that isn't acceptable
i mean there are many people
who will be able to tell you well those
things used to happen
in offices
up and down the country people bosses
would do mostly inappropriate things
and absolutely they are wrong they've
never been acceptable so those people
who have carried out those acts you know
should should be worried that there are
someone who's going to come forward
you know the allegations against those
people that were convicted
and the ones we're talking about were
very serious allegations yeah we're
talking about you know
full sexual contact and full
sexual abuse of children
yeah this is the premier league of
of predators that we're talking about
here
yeah well
yeah i mean
is our horrific nature and repeatedly
and repetitively and and of course
they've used their position of trust to
abuse them
in the country there will be other
people
and i went and spent half a day there
sat in a room with about 15 or 16 other
offenders in there and
part of the process is they have to be
very open about their behavior
each explaining the offenses they have
they committed
is that every single one of them said
at some stage they knew they were gonna
get caught it was just a matter of time
and it was one guy who said look you
know i used to come home from work and i
drove around the corner and
and i think in one way that's quite
reassuring that offenders think that
they will get caught one day
the sad reality is that they don't
always get caught uh and i spend most of
my time now spent away from my private
work around managing david's special
offenders he's very much around
investigating murders unsolved
and up and down the country there are
sadly people walking around who are
responsible for a murder who have got
away with it and have not yet got caught
and
that is that
what are some of the most disturbing
cases that you've investigated
i think the hardest ones are when i know
somebody is guilty i know someone has
done it i just can't get enough evidence
to get them prosecuted and that might be
a case of you know nicola payne who is
an 18 year old young girl he went
missing in coventry in 1991 and actually
we're featuring a case at crime con this
year and well i've done an awful lot of
work around that and i have no doubt who
the offenders are absolutely no doubt
the evidence is pretty compelling
against them but just not enough to get
them convicted i've got
another case that i've taken on more
recently which is the murder of two
young boys in liverpool
in the 1980s
and i've now managed to get an interview
with the person i believe responsible
and actually incredibly he has opened up
for the first time and has admitted to
being the last person that saw them
alive and admitted to something
happening
when he was with them and i hope you
know we're currently working on that to
try and get it to a position where we
make it into a programme
which forces the hands of the crown
prosecution services and the police to
arrest him and prosecute him they've
gone these are two young boys and the
case
for a lot of people don't even know
about it yeah that's horrific two boys
murdered in the 1980s why don't we all
know about that and there are other
cases
a big article recently about unsolved
murders because i did a freedom of
information request at every police
course to get details of their murders
unsolved murders and it is frightening
it is genuinely frightening how many
murders there are that remain unsolved i
mean there's there's a horrific case in
a young baby who was sexually assaulted
and then um
cemented into a barrel and
you know
most probably while she was still alive
you know that offender has ever been
caught or offended as a low-beam court
there's other cases there's another case
where an individual was cut up and put
into a big uh barrel
uh an oil barrel i mean there are
shockingly cases where offenders have
never ever been caused and that for me
is the
you know the the
the drive that makes me get out of bed
in the morning and go do you know what
i'm gonna go and try and catch somebody
else and i have you know i have an
incredible amount of
of workload
you know my next podcast on the
detective series is lee boxel
uh we're just cutting
episode one and that will be released
within the next couple of weeks and it's
a three passer and i and the evidence we
have uncovered is phenomenal it is you
know we
i will name who i think the killer is he
died
about six months ago actually died
during covid i wish he was still alive
and actually i probably couldn't i
couldn't have been so forceful if he did
being alive because of the uh of naming
him but he's now dead so i can name him
and i will have to go actually tell you
that i think he is responsible and
actually we've got evidence now from his
son and his daughter
who for the very first time have given
me some evidence which pinpoints him as
being the
offender what happened to
those
asian
guys that you featured in a series of
podcasts that you did what was the
comeuppance with them
so so that was for the first series of
the detective podcast which was the four
men in jail for a
terrorist attack they were accused of
being involved in a terrorist attack in
the west midlands
and quite clearly the evidence had been
planted by the
the police the police have planted the
evidence everything tells you that
there's no doubt even the judge
you know alluded to that he couldn't go
as far as to say that it was but
everything pointed that they constructed
it they put the put the matters there
but as is the case sadly for some of
these
things when they go wrong
very often the police will just close
ranks the judiciary will close ranks and
i can't tell you whether or not those
individuals
had any intention to commit a terrorist
attack in the uk what i can tell you
that the evidence that they were
convicted on was fabricated was made up
and it goes to the heart of any
investigation in fact my podcast uses
this at the very end is that
there is never in my mind a case where
the
means justifies the end so in other
words you can't make something up just
because you think it's right we have a
judicial system in this country and we
have to see that through properly
so by creating evidence by fabricating
evidence that for me is never acceptable
and i think that's what happened with
them and in fact in my series two of the
podcast
we look at a
lady that was a um
hindu sanghiri who was prosecuted for a
murder in manchester and
it's absolutely clear that it's not
murder it's suicide she got jailed for
what is a suicide and everyone thought
it was a suicide at the time and then
the senior investigating police officer
came in and as a result of the the
pathologist saying this looks like
murder
and then there follows a path where they
then go to prove murder they had no
evidence that it was murder in any way
at all
i've looked at it now we've done a full
forensic examination we've reconstructed
the crime scene we've reconstructed the
fight with the or the so-called fight
we've looked at the injuries and it's
now currently sitting with a new
pathologist who i hope will concur with
my decision
she's out of jail now she's no longer in
jail
she's just come out on license but she's
still a convicted uh killer and i hope
that the pathologist will concur with
with my conclusion and will get it to
the court of appeal and her
um verdict will be quashed and
interestingly the senior investigating
officer who i know actually who gave me
an interview and i think she probably
regretted massively giving me an
interview but she gave me an interview
and one of the
things i said to her is you know there's
no evidence to say that this was murder
everything pointed to suicide it all
looked like suicide the whole crime
scene looks like suicide you know why
did you decide that it was murder when
it looked like suicide yeah when it
looks like suicide it is suicide and her
response was if it looks like a duck it
quacks like a duck it's a duck and i
went exactly you know and what a strange
analogy for her to make i said well
you're spot on there you made the wrong
call didn't you she said well no i don't
think we did i said well you did you
know you put an innocent person to jail
i mean this is a person she never
she she's alleged to have turned up with
the knife in her handbag and then left
without taking the knife with her
and there's none of her forensics on
there and what makes this whole case
absolutely bonkers
is that it's based on the premise that
the the offender turns up at the crime
scene puts a whole forensic suit on
including gloves hats shoes
commits the murder
in the middle of the murder she changes
her her gloves and puts a different pair
of gloves on she then leaves the
property
not leaving a single trace outside of
the bedroom
takes her forensic suit off disposes of
her forensic suit somewhere
and that is the basis of the
prosecution's case that that's why she
had no blood on her clothes because she
carried it out wearing a full forensic
suit has that ever occurred at any other
crime in the uk
no not that i can find out has it ever
occurred in any other country
no
you know their analogy or the reasons
why they say that this had to be murder
was the sheer number of wounds that the
victim incurred
and
you know 40 plus wounds
but that takes out and what they failed
to acknowledge both the pathologist
and the senior investigating officer
is that that might be the case in your
limited understanding and research
around stab wounds but if you do a
little bit of research around the world
you'll find
that there are people who have stabbed
themselves in excess of a hundred times
and there are lots of cases where people
have carried out exactly the same types
of injuries that she had
and so when you do the research properly
when you look at it properly
it's a travesty it's an absolute
travesty she should never have gone to
jail and i hope that the pathologist
will concur with our decision and we'll
get it back to the court of appeal and
and she's languished in jail for those
years thankfully she's now home but
hopefully we can clear her name this is
some line of duty [ __ ]
it's funny already i mean you know by
and large the police are not corrupt at
all no
and in fact i often get asked this you
know do the police set people up
occasionally they do of course they do
it happens in every line of work and
particularly when you've got police
officers who held a lot of power
but overwhelmingly it's incompetence
it's overwhelmingly a vision that they
are right so one of the
positions of the murder manual is and
training is to allow senior
investigation officers to come up with
hypotheses in terms of of what's
happened because of course
the victim's dead and the only other
person that probably knows what's
happened is the offender
so you have to start guessing and you
have to start thinking well if this
evidence is telling us this this is
what's likely to have happened and
sometimes that's right but what ends up
happening is senior investigating
officers come up with this hypothesis
and then of course they then look for
evidence to fit that
and you can take all kinds of evidence
and make it as strong or as weak as you
want to make it and this is what happens
with scene investigating officers they
run down a blind alley to prove their
hypothesis
which unfortunately in itself when you
look at it in the light of day without
those blinkered visions blinkered
goggles on you look at and go that
doesn't make sense because what is the
likelihood
of an offender turning up at a crime
scene putting a whole forensic suit on
positioning the body in a certain way
leaving the knife there
coming out of the house making a phone
call immediately to a friend and telling
her exactly what happened within the
house
all of that doesn't make any sense and
it doesn't make any sense unless you
want to
change the narrative
to make it suspicious
yeah you're finding you're repurposing
the facts of the case in order to fit
the predefined idea that you have about
what happened
and that's what happens and it's
happened in many many cases it's
happened in um
jerry bamba it's happened in gildando
it's happened in this case and i'm sure
it's happened in a number of other cases
that you know
that i'm not aware of
speaking of line of duty apart from the
corruption and people shooting their
ways out of
of uh interviews and that really really
really long buzzer that happens when
they start an interview how accurate is
that as a a representation of what life
is like for the police yeah i mean it's
very accurate in many ways and you know
jed mccurry is a is a inspirational
writer he's very very clever i know
world productions very very well um
actually you know i've i've grown up in
their stable and have a very good
relationship with them they are
brilliant they're absolutely brilliant
but
of course you know there is poetic
license to some of it of course there is
um but overwhelmingly
it is it is pretty accurate
in most parts and some of it
i think probably the last series
slightly stretched the imagination in
certain ways
and it probably wasn't the best of
endings
no god what a [ __ ] [ __ ] way to finish
a season yeah
very disappointing really and i think
some of it got some
uh he got lost lost along the way
slightly yeah which is a real shame
because it is an amazing program
you corruption does happen in the
peaceful of course it does
uh because police officers are very
powerful people they can do an awful lot
of things more so
years gone by you know the 70s 80s and
90s police corruption was at its highest
really really bad
it's far less now because the police do
please themselves in sometimes better
than they please the public
which is disappointing um and i think
sometimes they go after ridiculous
things
but
line of duty
of course they go after ben's coppers
that's the basis of why there is um
you know ted's view is you know is that
he is after bent coppers all the time of
course they're around
and and they should be eliminated
they need to find those people and get
them out of the force as quickly as
possible
and people will cover up for other
people
organized crime is organized crime
involved in some aspects of policing
yeah i think that i think there will be
there will be
less so in the uk
you go to some of these other foreign
countries and absolutely i mean the
chief of police in in one of the areas
in thailand i think it's bangkok
he is currently on the run
you know he's on the run in relation to
having shot somebody in the head
with his team because they wanted him to
pay a 20 000 pound bribe and now they've
said
during the course of the interview they
actually upped it to i think 40 000.
but the background to him is that he on
his drive in his house he has ferraris
uh rolls royces
because the pla the pay is so bad for
the police in thailand that tends to
what happened is when they go to a
location to do a search or something if
they have cars there for the offenders
there's a picking order in terms of
seniority of the police
cars
and they will take the cars and that
becomes their own cars
and you take that to other countries you
know i've done a lot of work in cambodia
thailand
total corruption you buy yourself out of
these places in cambodia you know if you
get arrested in cambodia for child abuse
you can pay your way out of it
uh south africa you can do that you know
so the the corruption in in the uk
police force is palestine
in significance when you go to other
countries around the world
but it has been
significantly impacted on there's no
doubt that the british police force of
the 70s 80s and 90s compared to what it
is now
is a world away the corruption that
existed in the in those periods of times
was frightening
and thankfully the police has got a grip
of us so much of it now
and those people
are no longer in the police force
because there's no room for it there's
no room for it at all you know as police
officers
we have a
you know i say we i was yeah we signed a
note we signed a note to the queen to do
our duty to the crown
and
we it is down to us to act
professionally morally responsible the
whole time
and
we have to to keep that and whatever the
power is i mean you can see the power go
to some of these people's heads
but whatever it is then we have to be
upholding the law and the moment that we
step the wrong side of the law
then
we're as bad as they are aren't we
yeah did you watch murder next door that
chris watts yeah story what was your
what was your assessment of him
oh i mean firstly i have to say it's
probably the best program i've best film
i've watched all archive footage as well
wasn't it all police came and just
they filmed
accurate
in the moment
brilliant because of course it was all
on on that camera and uh
or interview stuff oh it's brilliant
brilliant i mean it was the best program
next they have done for for a very long
time
um
what a nasty piece of work i mean i
think
you know i've got a program that's
coming out very soon on channel five
which is about uh the yorkshire river
where basically the unheard tapes of the
yorkshire ripper i managed to get access
to someone who'd been visiting me in
prison for the last 15 years
and in his dying years i wanted her to
put to him uh cases that were unsolved
and information to get information from
him and she did that
and as a result of that we've got audio
recordings because she recorded all her
phone calls with him
and we've got those audio according and
i tell you what it's a fascinating
listen so that was that out
well we're waiting for a broadcast date
but it's likely to be september so we
was waiting for that it'll be on channel
five um and sold internationally as well
so that's very exciting uh but i think
what it tells you uh as a result of that
we did a lot of work around
looking at psychosis and
psychopathy and schizophrenia
and there is no doubt that
the
chris watts
had psychopathy he was able ah he was
able he was a psychopath he was able to
compartmentalize
his life
you know he wasn't in the form of the
schizophrenia which is up and down all
over the place he had a very very he was
very cool calm absolutely you know
really
dangerous piece of work and to be able
to
kill your children in that fashion in
that way
shocking that's the thing the amount of
trauma that you would go through
if you'd done it in a fit of rage if
you'd seen red
it would it would tear people apart most
people simply wouldn't be able to exist
they'd be shaking in the corner the ptsd
would be
unmanageable and yet he was able to
think rationally
drive them dispose of them come back
speak to the police trying
he was a psychopath which actually
it's interesting because of course
peter sutcliffe yorkshire ripper was
convicted and following his conviction
it ended up in the result of him getting
a core then deciding that he was a
psychopath
so he was schizophrenic schizophrenic
but actually that's the wrong category
he wasn't schizophrenic at all he was a
psychopath you know there was there was
no change in his behavior he'd commit a
murder he'd come home he'd get into bed
with his wife sonia and he'd wake up the
following day in normality go about his
business yeah
that's the sign of a psychopath and you
know and exactly what what's this what's
will forever be a psychopath
making a murderer what's your thoughts
yeah i mean i think you literally could
never have broadcasted british
television because it was totally
one-sided unbalanced um and lacked any
integrity from anything other than the
one side
um
it drew huge fans it was a massive
massive success but ultimately do i
think that
he was responsible yeah absolutely
i mean i i i you watch the program and
you come away after you think
yeah you're as guilty as hell you know
how on earth did
human remains end up in you know being
burnt in the grounds of your place you
know i'm sorry
that's this she was burnt there and you
would know about it
now the the cousin i think it's the
cousin brandon
brendan i mean i think brendan is
absolutely innocent uh and very sadly
we should never have ever been
prosecuted i mean the actions of that
investigator yeah pretty despicable
shocking absolutely shocking yeah he
should be convicted himself
uh and the defense you know were very
poor you know they could have really
highlighted a whole load of things that
would never have gotten convicted so
yeah a a great
visual and i suppose entertainment
program
but didn't do very much for any
credibility as a as an investigator
it was poor
the thing that's really interested me
during this conversation is
understanding the
forcing function
of putting something onto television to
cause downstream impacts with regards to
what happens judicially i i i would have
never thought watching how many seasons
of of your things on netflix now the
investigative thing
yeah
two seasons of that and consistent
one-offs and specials and so on and so
forth and you watch it and you think
well this is this is interesting it's
almost like it's there for our
entertainment but you forget
that after that airs there are
downstream implications that cause
investigations to be reopened within the
police for evidence to be looked at
because there's now societal public
pressure there's press attention there's
more um it galvanizes presumably the
families and other people as well that
are a part of that that to me is you
know
i enjoy watching
uh true crime on netflix i think they
have some really awesome stuff
but i never realized that it was
apart from being entertaining it's
actually
like a a service being done to the
investigation itself
all of my programs are there's a back
end to all of my programs they all have
a value they all have a purpose i mean
my most recent program on itv which was
the
murder of stephen clark you know as a
direct result of our involvement in that
program the parents got cleared of
murder
you know we we without us involving
without my involvement they would never
have been cleared and i don't know if
you've seen it but it's quite a
fascinating program
um and and i think you know the series
season
two
you know season one of the investigator
when we focus on
uh the factory i'm right season two when
we look at jesse earl's murder the young
girl in beachy head you know following
that
one of the areas that we focused on and
looked at is could we get a new inquest
because if we get a new inquest
potentially we can have the body doomed
and then we can collect some evidence
from the body the dna has never been
taken from before that's happening right
haven't you got some huge turnaround so
yeah so in relation to jesse earl on
series two we as a result of that have
or put in a very detailed application to
the attorney general
and we've now got a position where the
attorney general has allowed us to
appeal the conviction and we're waiting
now in for the high court to hear the
case
very soon and we're hoping that that
inquest will be overturned which is
unheard of you know you're lucky if you
get one inquest overturned every couple
of years they are so so rare so we've
managed to get that and the purpose of
it is and this is where the interest
comes in
so you could say okay well get them a
new inquest fine you know may get an
outcome which is positive but how's that
helpful well the situation is is that as
a direct result of that we are now
hoping that the body will be exhumed
that we can get dna from the body we can
put dna onto the national database we
can click we can check that dna across
the
unsolved crime database and the existing
marks and it might link up to items
being recovered from an offender that as
a result of that could be linked to her
so it all has a purpose
talk to me about the psychological price
that you pay for what you
do yeah i mean i think you pay a massive
price i didn't probably think that it
was
that big an impact on me until more
recently you know i have suffered my
mental health over the last two years
and and i do have dark days um which is
you know i never thought i'd talk about
really because of how dark it's been but
it has had an impact on me
um and i try and deal with it you know
sport and and
getting in the garden and those types of
activities have been really important
for me
but it is hard and i think it's hard
because
you're taking on other people's
pain taking on other people's sadness
and i live in a pretty dark world
because of the type of work that i do
but that said i love it i wouldn't do
anything else
i can't do anything else um and and i'm
passionate about what i do
looks like you're built for this and
like you were designed in some lab
somewhere to be
in this position
well if only i was was it i can't
remember the guy's name that was the six
million dollar man but that would be
lovely
[Music]
mark williams thomas ladies and
gentlemen if people want to keep up with
what you're doing where should they go
yeah so i've got a um instagram account
which is m williams thomas i've got a
twitter account which is m williams
thomas and i've got a tick tock account
which is emily so i keep them all up to
date with with crime related things
my next program to come out will be
the uh yorkshire ripper which is the
tapes of the ripper you can check out my
podcast at the detective which is on
that was on all the podcast platforms
and i'm currently working on i'll just
leave you with a bit of a tease i'm
currently working on a three-part
investigation into the disappearance of
madeleine mccann
serious stuff mark
thank you for today thank you very much
thank you take care bye-bye thank you
very much for tuning in if you enjoyed
that then press here for a selection of
the best clips from the podcast over the
last few months and don't forget to
subscribe
makes me very happy indeed
peace